how was the easter break
nice too short come on
we discussed this already but what would
be an appropriate length
for it
so every time by just two more weeks or
something
yeah well uh i don't know about
about uh austria but in hungary people
usually go to their friends you know
many people are coming over and we are
hanging out with other people
and you always have to drink their stuff
so
you you go there and and and we have
this drink that's called the piling cup
it's something like the schnapps but but
way stronger
and i told this to some some austrian
people and they were like oh my god
stronger than the schnapps
how can that be very easily at least in
hungary
so that's how it works and you you go to
the to the very first place and you have
to drink from their
home brewed awful palinka usually it's
very awful
and and you even have to say something
good about it so you drink it and it's
like
ah but you have to say something good
about this because they are they're
looking at you you know what will be the
reaction
so you say that that's that's really
strong and then most people seem to be
satisfied with that so like this is
usually what i say but
then when you are at like the fifth
station for that day
and and some people just don't take no
for an answer unfortunately
so this this is how it goes is it is it
any better in austria
it's more of a family holiday okay
okay yeah the family part is actually
the the nice part
so we we can decide if we drink our own
stuff or not
i mean my fiance's grandfather attempted
to make some
brew some palinko at home and well he
did something
so i mean something was created in the
process
but after after tasting it
even even the postman didn't want to
drink it
i don't know about postman in
austria but in in hungary they are like
really hardy people so they
they drink whatever they find because
because obviously you don't you don't
give the good stuff for the post menu
you give them
the leftovers it's like no no one drank
oh so it will be good for the postman
and he's happy with that imagine
they seem to like alcohol according to
my experiences so
yeah and and even the postman didn't
want to drink that anymore
so he like next time we have seen him
around the house
and he he just came like in front of the
main
main door and and and we wave to him
hey come we have some for you and he was
like no no i'm just gonna put them in
here
immediately okay so regarding the
assignments uh you guys and girls have
done really well so i'm very happy to
see that
people realize that there's some
exponentiality with respect
to the depth of the simulation so the
more
deep we go then the more exponential
things become but this is after like
i mean it's exponential all along but
you don't know this because it starts
out slow but after like 10 to 15 bounces
you you can you can see a very uh
italian characteristic of this
exponential distribution
and and many of you have recognized
correctly that this is because
refraction and reflection are sampled
all the time so whenever i have a bounce
i am going to compute an intersection
and then there's going to be two rays
perhaps that continue their way because
one is going to be
in the reflection direction and one is
with refraction
and this quickly gets out of hand
because forever ray you have two more
that's the definition of something
exponential
so well done let's proceed a bit i'm
going to talk just a bit about some
advanced
a bit more advanced brdf models that are
mostly used with
rate phasing so you remember this
conversion brdf that you see on the
right
and this is the scalar product between l
and then so the light
vector and the normal and obviously you
can scale this
with kd which is some kind of diffuse
albedo
now if you put it next to a real image
of a diffuse material obviously it is a
question you know what do we call a
diffuse material or
where was this photograph how exactly
but let's disregard this
and let's accept that we have this
difference between the two
and if you take a good look then it
becomes apparent that
in grazing angles
the simulated diffuse material
seems to be completely dark and if you
take a look at the formula up there then
this
this is a self-explanatory because the
normal
and the light direction and the normal
and the light direction
can get perpendicular and then you will
you will see this
darkness so there are some advanced prdf
models that
try to be a bit more realistic in this
regard
such example is the oren layer model
which is much closer to what you would
measure
in real life but let's note that
all of these simplified brd are small
drdf models these are all
texts this is not what physical reality
is
people write up the actual equations
that relate to physical reality and try
to simplify in a way that a simple brain
tracer can capture
and we are going to talk about global
effects and
what a real diffuse material looks like
in
humans so this rna or model seems much
better and what's even more
it can take into consideration these
microsoftic
in different materials and
you can get a roughness parameter that
can model
these imperfections
what about specular models well the
font model this v dot r that we have
talked about
is is not the only way to do it there is
also the
font blend model which is a more
advanced model and uses this h
is half vector between l and v and it
produces different results
i think this this image is maybe not the
best because
yes the highlights are different but one
of the main advantage
advantages of this material model is
that the shape of the specular
reflections can get a bit more elliptic
depending on the viewing direction and
the surroundings
so here you have the very same circular
thing
so it's not the best example but you can
see that it's different
it looks more realistic and we still
have to think about the fact that
these are still really good models but
that these are
still hacks
there's also the cook torrence model
that's basically foam blend that can
model
also microsoft roughness and
here maybe with the projector maybe it's
not so visible
but you can see that the specular
reflection here is a bit more
easier so it's not a completely
round sphere it's not a perfect sphere
there are
these small imperfections that are
characteristic to realize materials
so this is what this model can capture
and there are some
other advanced brdf models some of which
are more easy to understand and
implement than it is to pronounce the
name of the authors of the brdf models
this is one of those examples and this
is some kind
of a multi-layer model where you have a
diffuse substrate
and you have like a coating a specular
coating so there are
also brdfs for car paint where you can
have these
sparkly effects and
and there are many brdf models that
capture
given effects
okay what if one would like to play with
these the disney guys have implemented
this
program called the brdf explorer and you
can load many
local brdf models and change the light
source positions look at the actual
brdfs
and impulse responses give it a try
so we have always been talking about
cameras so we are trying to model real
world
cameras if you have a handheld camera
you will see a setting that's called the
f-stop
and the f-stop is related to the size of
the aperture the aperture
is is the opening of the camera where
the light goes in
and you can set this to different values
and
you will notice that if if you set this
f-stop to a high value
then the aperture of the camera is going
to become smaller
and if it's smaller then this means that
less light is let
in and more of the image that you get is
going to be in focus
and vice versa so if you have a low
f-stop setting
then you will have a bigger aperture
more light is let in
and more regions will be out of focus
and this is what gives you this depth of
field effect because
whatever images we have seen and created
with ray tracers yet
don't have this depth of field effect
but if you use a handheld camera then
somehow you have to model this effect as
well because this is
how an image would be created on the
field
so this is a nice chart made by
photographers
to see how exactly these f-stops relate
to
aperture size what are the typical
settings and
all of these interesting things
and an actual example so let's take a
look at
the bottom right here
you can see that the whole image is in
focus
and as you adjust the f-stop accordingly
you can see the top
left you can see here immediately that
the background
is heavily blurred so this is a more
pronounced
depth of field effect and it would be
wonderful to have a ray tracer that can
take
this effect into account and this is
another
maybe a bit more beautiful and a bit
more visible example
so on the left side you can see a very
pronounced up for field effect and on
the right
everything close to everything is in
focus yes do you
also use the word okay for commuter
graphics yes
yes and there is also
a bunch of papers on how to simulate
this effect so people even try to
compute this in real time so you have
like a computer game you would like to
see this bokeh
effect how do you do this and you have
to take into consideration the depth
like if you know what objects are where
exactly how far away
then you can do a bunch of tricks to to
to get
something like that an approximation in
real time
and if you do this something that i'm
going to show you in a second and you
will have the very same effect in your a
tracer so on the left
completely all in focus image on the
right you can see again
the depth of field effect especially in
the background
the further away you go the more you see
so how do we do this
very simple let's skip the text
and i just put this here because people
who read this at home
would know about this so mostly most of
what we do
is we shoot a rate through the midpoint
of the pixel in our range racer
and this is going to touch this focal
point and then hit an object
well what we could do is that we would
also take samples from nearby
so not only this pixel and not only the
midpoint but from nearby
and shoot all of these ways through the
same focal point
and compute the very same samples but
these samples will be nearby
what we do with these samples is we
average them
and this is what is going to give you
this depth of field
so this is already some kind of
integration this
means that which if you run a ray tracer
you're going to
get a completely converged image without
any noise
without any problems that image you can
consider
done but this will not be so with global
illumination
this is a speciality of raytracers but
if you have such an effect
then you may have to wait until more and
more of these samples are computed
and the more smooth image you will get
we will talk about this effect
extensively it's going to be
very important and just an important
question what kind of material model can
this be
obviously this is some quick perhaps
opengl preview
but it's very apparent what i see in
here
what kind of shading is this
is it specular these are definitely not
mirrors okay
what else
yes exactly so this is a lamborghini
model
and you can also see this effect that it
goes
completely black in these spacing cables